[Music]
could you just explain what the
union means to you the united kingdom
the union of the united kingdom for me
it's the greatest political partnership
the world
has ever seen it would be such a
shame to lose the power the magic
of that union and we are much much
stronger
and better together than broken up
but if it is magic why are we seeing
things
like this i don't think boris really
cares about northern ireland
particularly
i think the dominant commons cares even
less
when the uk government talks about four
nations approach they tend to mean
they come along tell us what the
decision is and expect us to fall into
line
i feel like we're very separated
already we've probably taken it for
granted for a bit over generations of
the union
is there and nothing will ever really
disturb it
brexit is a major challenge for the
union both scotland and northern ireland
we vehemently opposed the brexit deal
and what i have to do
is make sure that i mitigate against the
damage to the union
after everything that politics have
thrown at us over the last
five years embarking on another row
about identity and legitimacy and flags
felt well unnecessary but that was
before coronavirus came along which
does not respect the status quo or
political boundaries meaning it's
getting
ever harder to ignore those voices
asking whether or not the united kingdom
is fit for purpose
the claim to be tested over coming
months and years
is that coronavirus has bolstered the
chances of scotland breaking away from
the rest of the united kingdom
through a crisis over the last six
months perhaps people have
in scotland have seen that no matter how
difficult the challenges you face
you can do better and you can navigate
your way through it better
if you're in charge of your own
decisions and your own fate rather than
having that
decided by people elsewhere she's in the
position where she is
looking you know talking to people about
their safety and about
dealing with the virus the difficulty
for the uk government is we're in the
position where we're talking also about
funding the you know 900 000 jobs in
scotland we're supporting
six and a half billion of financial
support to the scottish government
it's it's more difficult for the people
who are paying for it
uh to go through the pandemic than
someone who is
if you like dealing with the health
aspect of it but not dealing with the
financial aspect of it not writing the
checks
dealing with both aspects of this
pandemic have been the businesses
particularly those on the borders their
lives complicated by the divisions and
differences between the nations
i think it could have been a more joint
up approach i see
the people that were pro-independents
even more so now i see people that were
on the fence
warming to nicolas ergen and what she
could do
for scotland as an independent country
scotland like wales and northern ireland
got through coronavirus with the help of
the furlough scheme
funded by the united kingdom
collectively
but for some young independent
supporters they still want to break away
fully aware
of the uncertainties this causes it
would be scary to say if we did voted
vote for independence and we had
the pandemic happened and i was on
furlough and i would
not have been paid for how many months
it would have been a
massive struggle so i can see the
positives and there is so many positives
have been in the united kingdom but i
also
believe that we could and we we don't
we don't know until we if we until we do
it
the big question is how a referendum
happens in the first place
there is no reason to doubt boris
johnson when he says that one will not
happen
while he is prime minister but that
doesn't mean that one won't happen at
all
so no in all circumstances to
independence is your view
yes and no in all circumstances to a
referendum is your view
well there is no case uh for a
referendum
when we are still in the midst of a
pandemic
it's just the tories use the language of
never and use the language of
no plans and people will hear the
difference oh
i'm saying that we will be going into
the elections
for the scottish parliament next year on
a manifesto
platform saying we do not support a
second independence referendum so we
will seek to get a mandate
from the people for that position
over the iris sea from hollywood to
hollywood a unionist heartland in
northern ireland
and a mother and daughter here showing
unions can go their different ways
a generational divide that rings alarm
bells amongst those who oppose
any talk of northern ireland reuniting
with the republic
what does the union mean to you it means
stability
for me i think and i think my
generation would sort of feel the same
what does the union mean to you well
i've never had to ask myself
that question before um so i don't
i don't really know but at this moment
in time
um less and less
the public is often far less sentimental
and much more practical about questions
like
what country they want to live in i
don't think there's many people wanting
united island just
people say because the
level of living here is much higher
do you see that creation of a new island
imminent i think the conversation has
very seriously begun if you had to point
to specifics
that show that demonstrate cooperation
on a scale we haven't seen
recently or before what would they be we
have two world-leading contract chasing
apps that have allowed us to
combat the virus as best as possible on
a north side basis
we have had cooperation around keeping
vital trade links and transport links
open through your two transport
ministers
there's been cooperation around the
hospitality sector and how that has
opened
in a staged a managed way don't read
too much into these moves insist
northern ireland's first minister
recently there have been quite a lot of
issues
where northern ireland and the republic
have cooperated
is there a pattern of moving a bit more
to an all island approach
we will cooperate of course and share
information uh with our neighbours in
the republic of ireland because it's the
right thing to do
for our own citizens here in northern
ireland if you take the app for instance
we decided to develop our app in a
similar way so that it is
interoperable with the app that's coming
on the mainland and also with the app
in the republic of ireland that's
sensible i don't apologize for that
also not apologizing for brexit but
having to implement a deal that she
doesn't like
done by a prime minister she helped put
in number 10.
we vehemently opposed the brexit deal i
think it did damage
the relationship uh between the two of
us
i have to recognize that that is the
reality now and what i have to do
as the leader of unionism in northern
ireland is make sure that i mitigate
against the damage to the union
the future of the union has too often
been boiled down
into a pantomime boris versus nicola
hero and villain and which side is which
depends on your point of view
but as one of the most senior unionists
in the country told me it's
not scotland whose place is most at risk
it's northern ireland only they have a
constitutional
right to a vote on their status in the
uk
not the scots when the will
to continue started to dissipate and new
strategies emerged
we started to move towards the ira
ceasefire of august 94
and the loyalist ceasefire of october
94.
tour guide paul donnelly explains to
outsiders how today's northern ireland
is the product of bombs and ballots
but political uncertainty is the most
destabilizing thing at the moment
the uncertainty about the union whatever
direction it's going to go in sort of
feeds into my everyday work
and you know it's it's the economy
stupid for many people is the bottom
line of anything
i find that my working life and my
economic life just feels slightly
fractious and uncertain at the moment
there are posts and flags here 300 miles
east on the welsh english border
but they mean different things the
consequences of devolution
limited self-government here cause
grumbling
now we're walking through from england
into wales onto hall number seven
the welsh government was more
restrictive in terms of
allowing people out to do things it
caused quite a bit of
uncertainty and confusion in the members
as far as i could see
because the you had this difference in
standard that was being applied
you've got ministers going up and saying
different things about what should be
quite common guidelines
the idea that wales or scotland or
england or north london may
just do things differently because they
can i think that is quite frustrating if
you happen to be a business or a
family or a charity or an individual
which may particularly in wellesley's
case
have significant cross-border uh
interests
and give rise to people thinking well
actually this is about politics it's not
about
the economy or it's not about covid
what's happening here in
wales matters because unlike scotland
and northern ireland there aren't
nationalists in the administration
trying to redraw the map of the united
kingdom as we know it
now the labour welsh first minister is
no friend of boris johnson but he admits
he couldn't have got an independent
wales through the pandemic
without the help of the westminster
treasury which means
english taxpayers paying for that
furlough scheme
he preaches unionism without as many
union jacks could he be a
poster boy for keeping the four nations
of the united kingdom together
right across the united kingdom we've
done broadly similar
things but our messaging has been
different it has brought home
to people the nature of devolution and
the fact that we have a welsh government
here
in a way that nothing else has done in
20 years could you ever see the day
that wales separated off from england if
the united kingdom were to fracture
then everybody will have to think about
the way in what remains can go on
working for everybody
i am very clear that if a population in
scotland or indeed in wales
wanted to hold a referendum it is for
the people of wales and the people of
scotland to make that decision
and then that decision must be respected
a
sovereign nation choosing to alter its
borders is
the most momentous decision it can take
but in this era of continually
accelerating political turmoil
perspective alters coronavirus has
revised some people's priorities
if change is going to happen to the
union it may already
be too late to stop it sam code sky news
you